ok well the campaign started as the No
campaign but obviously the questions
been changed and pretty much we've
rebranded it's a lead or EU and
effectively what we've done is we've
been out to talk to all of the lead in
your skeptic campaigns I haven't always
been the best of friends the seven of
them including you Kiev bridge-group
democracy movement all different
groupings and effectively we're trying
to bring them all together under one
umbrella supporting what we're doing
which is a non political campaign
we are different from you Kip we've got
60 people working on facade of Bristol
we've got a big social media operation
got different people coming on to the
campaign businessman sports people all
sorts of different people we've also
hired a chief strategist from America
that's probably the best person in the
world to fight referendum 3232
referendum is 130 I think the other two
were pulled actually fair enough sees
his track rockwood is one hundred
percent and so Nigel's part of it but is
not the only game in town
well I'm not sure that there you were a
skeptic I mean they haven't actually
said whether they're in or out there
waiting for the Prime Minister's
renegotiation Dominic come in says he
wants two referendums I'm not too sure
how that works but from our point of
view we'd met with Matthew Elliott on
three separate occasions we've asked him
to come into the grouping and his basic
bottom line is is that that they haven't
said they're out so how can they join a
an umbrella group of people that would
have been out with their not a house
I think it will be a combination of the
economy and immigration the two
obviously pretty critical but I think
immigration would be the number one
followed by the economy
well I need a referendum that's good to
start from slightly behind you I know
that sounds strange but the Great
British public haven't actually focused
on the issues yet and I'm pretty
convinced when they do they realize
Britain can do better and that's what
will be out there trying to persuade
people
doug has had a few strong words of me
not the other way around I wished him
well and went to my way
he took exception to something written
in the garden you'd have to as I say go
and ask him
absolutely you know he's part of the
business for Britain grouping maybe he
was a little bit put out about today's
announcement I don't know but from our
perspective will work with anyone that's
interested in getting Britain out in the
European Union